qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens bas par rapport à
2,1 à beaucoup et donc du coup c'est
plutôt bien des services et
beaucoup de beaucoup de monde j'évoque
chan en pense quoi
arrêté il ya un moment les transports on
en a marre avec ma soeur c'est de la
merde et encore je dis moi je veux pas
le dire
j'adore la mer persie aussi et bien
c'est cher j'hésite entre prendre des
tickets et où prendre la carte qui est à
70 euros maintenant pour pour l'ensemble
mais qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent votre
frère on parle coco 30 me donner sur
paul de transport jahtari sable à
bourdonner new browser
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
moi j'habite dans l'ouest donc je prends
rarement à les transports en commun pour
venir généralement c'est plutôt la
voiture est votre chat on pense quoi
photo la même chose parce que c'est vrai
que sur un bété donc on attend simple
plus utiliser la boîte sur quoi vient
enfin pas peur les jumelles
qui sont souvent retard et
qui ne respectent pas souvent way leurs
horaires après c'est plutôt pratique
dans
en règle générale surtout quand on
habite en banlieue comme moi d'accord et
on ferait il en pense quoi a grillé